I heard you talking on a show where you
met Donald Trump yes but not quickly
because you wanted to no I was just I
love real estate I have to go meet when
I was here I was like I was I was like
11 or 12 and I was going it was when we
were doing press for the first potter
movie where they took us to new york and
it was the first time doing sort of the
morning shows in New York I was about to
go on The Today Show
I've never been on sort of American good
morning TV before and it's quite nervous
and Donald Trump was also had also been
on that day and so they did that's
Donald Trump for those of you who have
literally forgotten what he loved then
they sort of walked me over to him
because clearly they were like you know
somebody said hey you want to kitty
place Harry Potter and he was like sure
conversation went but they sort of
walked me over to him and he said oh hi
nice to meet you and I said nice to meet
you
and I said he said how are you and I
said I'm really I'm quite nervous I died
I've never been on TV for I don't really
I don't know what I'm going to talk
about and he brilliantly just said you
just tell them you met mr. Trump that is
the that is the Everest of
self-confidence
hey man if I just been to you like when
you go on that show just talk about me
your stuff look at these new Americans
and we're both just like like sad yeah I
know you're all laughing those are the
problem also this is kind of the problem
could you do end up talking about him
yeah and you know we should be talking
about the ugly people I know you're I
mean the beauty of the whole thing is
you have to cuz he just doesn't talk
about himself you feel like you hit
we've got we've got photographic proof
of you liking Baker yes I'm gonna be
knee
[Applause]
you